Muhammad Abu Bakr flips through the
pages of his books he was hoping to be a
doctor but the fighting in Sudan put a
stop to his
studies it's not good staying here
without school that will be the end of
my dreams to be a medical
doctor second year medical student Amar
Aria doesn't see hope in the near
future the way things are there is no
hope of returning home anytime soon let
alone continue our
studies he says at least his generation
can read and write but fears more for
the small Refugee children he sees
here Aid agency official in Char's board
town of adre say there are no schools
for the hundreds of thousands of newly
arrived sudanes
refugees the refugee population here has
crossed the 600,000 Mark most of them
are under under the age of
30 that number continues to
grow a workers say even if this children
eventually get into a classroom there is
another problem the curriculum in Sudan
is different from what is taught here in
China so to get the children engage
parents send them to religious schools
like this to
study the priority for now is to provide
shelter and food and even that is
grossly
inadequate overcrowded public schools in
ad can't take in any Refugee child for
thousands an entire school year is now
wasted there is no clear indication as
to when Refugee students will be able to
return home and to their classes ahammed
Idris Al jazer on the chart Sudan
border make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer